NBA star Kevin Love is known for his
basketball IQ his rebounding and his
three-point shot on the court he has a
five-time All-Star an Olympic gold
medalist and he helped the Cleveland
Cavaliers win their first championship
in 2016. but behind the wins love hit
his mental health struggles love says he
first first faced anxiety and depression
as a teenager but was able to focus on
basketball then in 2017 he had a panic
attack during an NBA game he shared his
challenges in a personal essay titled
everyone is going through something and
got help in 2018 he started the Kevin
Love fund to inspire others to live
their healthiest lives physically and
mentally now they're launching a new
program which gives teachers a free
curriculum to help students fight mental
health challenges that is awesome Kevin
Love joins us right now how you doing
man I'm happy to be here guys so how did
the idea come about
uh it really came about after my uh my
panic attack that you alluded to like in
November of 2017 I had a panic attack
excuse me on court it was a very public
moment something I had felt like I had
to hide you know things got a lot worse
before they got better but I started
going to therapy
um got my medication Right started doing
the work on myself and then it wasn't
until March of 2018 where I actually
penned that essay that you mentioned in
the players Tribune and just the
response that I got from that article
and after the fact there was thousands
and thousands of emails within the first
week and everything leading up to
September 19th of that year and that
fall it led me into you know creating
the Kevin Love fund with the intention
of providing tools for both physical and
emotional well-being so we've now
piloted this program for the last couple
years we found The Sweet Spot you
mentioned my teenage years of of you
know starting my struggle with mental
health uh and for me that's where we
felt like in our directors of Education
felt like the The Sweet Spot was and
being able to impact and affect people's
lives because it is such a limiting
factor of of course of potential
especially for these kids in the Next
Generation so it's really exciting to
get this off the ground and you know
have it be free to every school every T
every teacher Nationwide is awesome as
of October it sounds like something you
would have wished were available when
you were a teenager 100 and people ask
me all the time they say you know what
would you tell your younger self and for
me it was you know you're allowed to be
vulnerable you know as a as a young
woman or a young man you're allowed to
be vulnerable and within the classroom
like you don't the most important thing
for me is you don't have to go down the
hallway
with this class you don't have to go
down the hallway with this curriculum
you know the teachers are are modeling
vulnerability first and then within the
classroom your peers are allowed to to
share their stories uh there's 14
different lesson plans where you get to
share I laugh because I think about when
I was young uh you know through
different mediums like photography uh I
wrote a first person poem about my late
grandmother but I laugh because music
music has such a way of it's in my
family but has such a way of of making
you know even like when you listen to
sad songs you actually feel kind of
happy yes yeah and your music is very
healing it's very yeah it's very healing
so I'm the type of guy even when I go to
games people ask me what's on my
playlist for me it's a lot of stuff
without words it's instrumental stuff
that gets you just calmed down and it
kind of alleviates the stress and
anxiety of going through a game and
having to perform so it's no different
for these kids having to share their
first person stories through music like
I mentioned through different mediums
photography creative writing poetry so
on and so forth so the process of going
the process of going public with your
with your struggles it must have been
hard for you to finally make the
decision to do it and then once you did
you must have felt very relieved and
especially in sports where right that's
a really good takes over yeah right and
I mean honestly I wasn't the first one
there's a lot of you know young men and
young women that have come to before me
but for me within my sport it was DeMar
DeRozan I mean without him
and him you know dipping his toe in you
know jumping in head first if not for
him I don't know if I'd be sitting here
today and having you know shared my
story at the capacity and at the level
that I did but you said something I
think really important about the program
and how it works in the classroom you
said the kids don't have to go down the
hall yeah and the process of going down
is what is stigmatizing right and
there's still a stigma attached to this
right a degree of Shame like something's
wrong and you shouldn't be acknowledged
it right how do you address that I mean
it's working in the classroom with the
program but how do you get rid of it in
a bigger way I think it's continuing to
have these conversations I mean just the
fact that we're all all four of us are
sitting there here
speaking about it and especially when
kids are so susceptible to change like
that that sweet spot that I mentioned
whether it's middle school high school
early college all the way throughout
College being able to especially with
all the pressures now of being uh you
know a young person and having to you
know think about college think about
sports think about the Arts and just
having to perform the whether it's
pressure from your parents whether it's
pressure from your peers your teachers
so on and so forth we don't want them to
have to go down the hall we don't want
them to have to go to their counselors
right even though that's available we
don't want them to have to go to the
vice principal the principal we wanted
to want them to do it with their peers
and feel like they can be vulnerable and
models in the safe space in the
classroom Tony that's such a good image
of going down the hall because when
you're a great metaphor yes nobody wants
to go down the hall could we talk about
your marriage I'm sorry okay
congratulations weddings I'm so excited
for you Kevin because I remember I like
it well I mean not everybody's
comfortable talking about their wedding
but number one the pictures were great
Kate looked fantastic
but I love that episode first dance
there yeah look at that what was the
song what was the song for firsthand uh
it was That's Where It's At by Sam Cooke
that's where it's at yeah nice but do
you are you with newlywed when I first
got married I'm divorced but that's no
not a story when I first got married I I
love being able to Bears mentioning yeah
but I love being able to say my husband
this my husband that my husband I tried
to think of a sentence where I could say
my husband are you that kind of guy too
it was great I think you know I take a
lot of pride in that now it's like I get
to say this is my wife my wife new to me
but I you know I look at my wife Kate
every time I'm like this is new and this
is fun I like this but for we had a
longer engagement as well it was almost
about a year and a half because of covid
we wanted everybody to come in and enjoy
themselves at the wedding and not really
have to to worry about that
um but it was it was amazing it was
amazing we did at the New York Public
Library yes it was beautiful the best
thing about her is what best thing about
Kate I just think you know her
temperament who she is
um
her family is incredible you could tell
that she was raised right she's a sweet
girl she's from the Pacific Northwest
Canadian that
my part about it
I love when the professional and the
personal lines up congratulations thank
you so much